more than 17,000 cases worldwide and at
least 360 deaths the corona virus
continues to spread with many fearing
the peak is yet to arrive but the
situation so far has been enough to
prompt some countries into evacuating
their citizens from China among them
South Korea Japan the United Kingdom
France Germany India and the United
States many others are planning
evacuations at least one that isn't is
Pakistan the government says this is in
the court larger interests of the region
cold comfort particularly for the
Pakistani students stuck in and around
Wuhan some 800 of them according to the
Pakistani embassy in China there have
been growing calls in Pakistan itself
for the government to bring these
students back many have been sending
social media and video messages asking
to be evacuated here is a message from
some in the city of Jing Zhu an hour's
drive from Wuhan more than 300
Pakistanis are here with us we're
appealing to the Pakistani government
through the SAR in Boerne trust to
please get us out of here as soon as
possible because we're under mental
torture and can't stay here long please
please please rescue us from here
similar pleas are being made by other
students in China as well such as this
one demanding that the Pakistani
government step in and help evacuate
these students others are criticizing
the Pakistani government for leaving
them in the lurch for the first time in
our life
we're embarrassed to say we are from
Pakistan the refrain there the Pakistan
government has responded to these pleas
here's what it had to say some people
may perhaps ask this question because
many things have appeared on videos on
social media in which people are asking
for evacuation I can show you similar
messages to us from Wuhan in which
students have written to us
that we are being looked after very well
we were being provided with everything
and the Chinese government is doing so
much for us in this regard this what
home are you feel a it is our thinking
that it would be better for our loved
ones those who are in China and in the
larger interest of the region our
country and the world not to evacuate
them at the moment but since Monday
regular commercial flights with
Pakistani students on board have started
arriving in Pakistan for more on the
situation in China I'm joined by
Pakistani student has an entity from
Channing just south of Rohan has man
thanks for joining us I'd like to first
start by asking where you are right now
and what is your situation there yeah
I'm Hassan and St from Shannon Shannon
is just 40 minutes drive from main
ethnic center of Rohan so we are in very
bad condition we are trapped in our
rooms and no one from our government is
taking responsibility and taking care
for us and in in my city more than 600
cases are confirmed and more than
thousand cases are is are to be
suspected so so there is no
transportation our city's totally locked
on no trains no airports
we are just trapped in our rooms and no
one is here to help us but despite that
no commercial flights from China have
begun landing in Pakistan do you think
that now you will be able to leave for
Pakistan no that that statement from our
health minister is totally wrong because
just know I I have talked to Pakistan
and bassy that can we leave
Shannon leave China but their response
was that you can't leave who before us
because who by pollens
totally lockdown there's no
transportation no trains no flights how
can we leave we leave from here we are
just tapped here and even our university
gates are are closed we can't leave even
can't leave our city even can't leave
our university and university is getting
is asking us to get permission from
government and government is asking you
can't leave from China because you are
in an epicenter and our our our blame is
dead just we are trapped in epicenter
and we can't can't escape from here yeah
as to enjoy State thank you very much
for speaking to us and monitoring the
situation is cheb Jelani from DW asia he
joins me on the line now ashes Abe you
heard Haas name there clearly
unsatisfied with the response from the
Pakistani government what really is the
real reason that Pakistan doesn't want
to evacuate its citizens from China well
as you were just hearing earlier on the
official stance is that Pakistan does
not want the the disease to spread it is
acting under the w-h-o guidelines and
the Chinese have assured them that we
will take care of the situation but the
real reason we all know is the special
relationship between China and Pakistan
this situation is a real test for the
Chinese leadership on how it deals with
this crisis
it wants Pakistan to play ball and
Pakistan is saying we trust the Chinese
Dave that our people will be better
taken care of there then in Pakistan
because frankly Pakistan's health system
is in complete shambles and there's a
fear if people start arriving then
Pakistanis will not be able to contain
it what is the response been in Pakistan
itself shows it to the government's
unwillingness to actually evacuate its
citizens the government has been deeply
criticised editorials have been written
commentators on social media have
questioned that you know how can you
leave your people in this situation we
were just hearing from Hassan and chesty
helpless
and stranded but Pakistan is saying we
have to look at a bigger picture imagine
if your brother or your son was standard
there will you pay attention to the
government's official point of view not
really so many families are perturbed
and they are asking the government to
have a rethink I think we also need to
point out here shows if that commercial
flights these are regular commercial
flights have began landing in Pakistan
from China some by way of Doha and it
could appear at least from the tweets of
their special advisor to the pakistan
Prime Minister on health that that
appears to be something the Pakistan
government is publicizing and saying
that look Pakistani students are coming
home is that really what the Pakistan
government is trying to do yeah I mean
earlier on Monday when these flights
arrived the government Minister was
there the Chinese ambassador was there
and later both of them addressed a new
conference news conference and the
Chinese ambassador really appreciated
Pakistan's standing shoulder-to-shoulder
with China so the two governments are
clearly trying to put a united stance
regarded front they are saying we are in
this together and they are appreciating
each other
meanwhile these students are our
standard and their families are deeply
worried in Pakistan what precautions is
partisan taking to prevent the spread of
the virus
well the gilgit-baltistan government
which is the northern region which
borders China it was scheduled to reopen
last week the government has decided to
now keep it closed until April so they
want to restrict people coming in and
going out this is the the gateway for
the the seatback project China Pakistan
corridor which the two countries have
spent billions in so the government is
saying we are taking those kind of
precautions they have also alerted
health facilities and doctors but
clearly if China and other countries
can't deal with distant Pakistan has to
be worried about how to tackle this
problem
Josep Jelani thank you very much for
that